My name is Sarmad and today I want to
talk about building effective agents
with model context protocol or MCP. So a
lot has changed in the last year. Um
especially as far as agent development
is concerned. I think 2025 is the year
of agents and uh things like MCP make
agent design simpler and more robust
than ever before. So I want to talk
about what the agent tech stack looks
like in 2025. The second thing is a lot
of uh MCP servers today are just you
know onetoone mappings of existing REST
API uh uh services to MCP tools. Uh but
MCP servers can be a lot more than that.
They could even be agents and so I want
to show how uh agents can be represented
as MCP servers. And the last thing is uh
a little bit of a look into uh agent
architecture and modeling agents as
asynchronous workflows with workflow
orchestration uh infrastructure like
airflow, temporal etc.
So, a little bit about me. I'm the CEO
of Last Mile AI and I've in the past uh
been working on developer tools uh for a
while for many years and back in 2016 to
2018 I was working on uh language server
protocol and language servers at at
Microsoft. U LSP revolutionized.
Here on the right you can kind of see uh
the list of hundreds and hundreds of
language servers that are now available.
But before this uh every IDE had to had
a unique API surface and so every
language server had to implement uh you
know VS code specific way of doing
things or an Eclipse specific way and it
was very fragmented as an ecosystem and
LSP completely you know changed that uh
by standardizing a single interface API
interface for how language services
should be exposed in IDE and so when uh
you know LLM LM took off even before
tool calling was a thing. I've been
thinking about what it would take to
make a LSP style protocol for LLMs. Now,
I've been thinking about this for a long
time. Here you have this like scratch
pad from 2023 where uh this is the era
of you know chat GPT plugins and uh I
was thinking of how you know u agent
authentication should work or how LLM
should be connected to tools, resources,
data in some way. Uh and so model
context protocol which enthropic created
a few months ago has been a godsend and
I think it incorporates a lot of the
things that uh are really necessary to
to get um you know agents into
production and we'll talk a little bit
about that. Like I stated before I think
2025 is the year that agents hit
production uh on mass. Uh until now
there have been a lot of uh high uh
impact use cases that our customers see
that have been stalled in proof of
concept stage. Things like you know
people want to work do workflow
automation. They want to uh deal with
unstructured data uh and process it in
interesting ways. Uh they want to do
information retrieval. And you're
starting to see agents appear in each of
these categories already. And I think
that pattern will accelerate uh in the
coming months.
So what does the tech stack look like
for agents in 2025? There are three big
uh kind of updates or changes that are
happening um which I think uh allow you
to build effective agents uh much more
easily than ever before. So the first
thing is better models. We have uh
reasoning models and LLMs that are
pretty reliable for a lot of use cases.
And with test time compute uh a lot of
the complexity things like you know
chain of thought reasoning uh or react
or other kind of patterns that had been
implemented at the framework layer are
actually now shifting left into the
inference layer. And all that uh allows
is for less complexity and less burden
for app developers because they can get
a lot more done by just invoking a model
API than ever before.
The second thing is model context
protocol uh or MCP for folks who are not
familiar. MCP is basically a
standardized interface for connecting
LLMs to tools to data to resources to
the world around them. Um and so the
really re the revolutionary thing about
it is that it is a single way it
provides a single interface to connect
and give context to LLMs. Uh whereas in
the past there used to be uh you know a
multitude of data connectors that were
platform specific that you'd have to
integrate with
and MCP has taken off. you know like
Google, OpenAI, Microsoft, many other
companies potentially competitors uh
have all kind of coalesed around MCP uh
and so it is going to become the de
facto standard for how LLMs connect to
the world around them.
And the last part that's really uh
changed in the last few months is
there's simpler architectures for uh how
agent applications should look. agents
today unlike the past are now simply you
know orchestrators of better models and
MCP uh and connecting LLM to these tools
and resources using these standard
protocols u in some well-defined
patterns. There's no longer a need for
monolithic AI frameworks that did a lot
of heavy lifting at the framework layer
in the past. Uh now you can have simple
agent patterns. You implement them with
u standard protocols with good LLMs and
you can get a long way. And just to show
you uh Anthropic at the u uh end of last
year, beginning of this year released
this very influential blog post called
building effective agents. And in it
they highlighted a couple of agent
patterns that work well in production
from their experience with uh you know
deploying agents uh into enterprises.
And so the simplest example of this
pattern is this thing called an
augmented LLM which is basically an LLM
that has access to tools and resources
or data. Uh and you basically you know
it's the base building block. You run
this LLM in a loop. It gets an input. It
may call tools, it may retrieve data in
order to do its job and it runs you know
several uh iterations and returns a
response at the end. And then you can
build more interesting patterns on top
of that. So then you could have an
augmented LLM which is the optimizer uh
that generates a response and you can
connect it to another augmented LLM uh
which is the evaluator that evaluates
the quality of the generated response
and gives feedback to the to the
generator LLM uh to see what it could do
better. And this process happens over
like a set of uh iterations until the
evaluator LLM is happy with the quality
of the response and then it you know
returns the final response to the user.
You could have you know distributed
systems practices like fanning out to
multiple uh sub agents and then fanning
back in uh to aggregate the results. And
perhaps the most sophisticated one which
we're starting to see in uh tools like
claw code and other uh you know agentic
systems is this idea of an orchestrator
where you have one LLM that does that
generates a plan and uh assigns tasks to
sub aents uh dynamically and then
synthesizes the results uh before
responding back to the user. And this
process can also run in a loop. But
really the idea is that there is a
planner that is reasoning and deciding
uh what to do next kind of dynamically.
So, uh, what I did towards the end of
last year, uh, as part of my Christmas
break was, uh, I wanted to build an
agent, uh, library that implemented all
of the patterns that this building
effective agents blog post, uh, had, uh,
and basically was very opinionated about
the world being MCP native in the very
near future. And so that's what I built.
It's called MCP agent. Uh, it's on
GitHub. You can check it out. uh and it
is basically making a few very key
opinionated choices. One is that MCP is
going to be everywhere. So every line of
business application uh think like you
know notion, Google docs, cursor or
cloud is soon going to be an MCP
compatible client. Uh so that means that
it could connect to MCP servers. And on
the flip side I think every service this
is already starting to happen is going
to have an MCP server equivalent uh for
it. And so you're going to see things
like, you know, a linear MCP server, a
GitHub MCP server, and any kind of like
SAS product that needs to expose itself
to LLMs will have an MCP server.
The second thing that I'm going to show
in a little bit is that agents should be
thought of as uh microservices and they
can be deployed as MCP servers
themselves. And as we'll talk about in a
little bit, that actually gives a lot of
benefits on how multi-agent interactions
can work.
And the last part is agents are async
workflows and they should be modeled as
such because they can be paused,
resumed, retried. You may have a human
in the loop. Uh and that's really a
workflow orchestration that's
asynchronous instead of something that's
uh you know happening in your chat
session in proc.
You know, if you think of um agentic
behavior in the MCP world today, it all
happens on the client side. So, you use
claude or cursor and they in turn use
MCP servers to solve your the tasks you
give them. But what if agents themselves
were exposed as MCP servers? In that
case, if if you connect an agent as an
MCP server to an MCP client, then that
client uh can invoke that agent. It
could coordinate uh across multiple
agents. It could orchestrate similar to
the patterns I showed you the same as it
does today with any other MTP server.
Also, you could do multi-agent
communication also over MCP. So, agents
can then invoke other agents. In this
diagram, you kind of see an MCP client
that's connected to MCP regular MCP
servers like GitHub, Slack, Linear, etc.
But it's also connected to agent
servers. uh and these agent servers in
turn can connect to other MCP servers uh
just over the base MCP protocol. Uh and
so then you can kind of get multi-agent
collaboration and coordination for free.
The MCP client can invoke in this case
MCP agent server A which in turn may
invoke other MCP servers or it may even
invoke other agents. uh and as a result
you basically have this network of
agents that uh may get activated from a
single command that a user sends through
cloud cursor or some other MCP client.
So what are the benefits of this? If you
expose agents as MCP servers, the first
thing you get is composable agents. Like
I mentioned, you have complex
multi-agent systems that can operate
over the same base protocol that
everybody's adopting. We know MCP is
going to be a common standard and so we
can uh safely build on top of it. The
second thing is you get platform
agnostic agents. You can build these
agents once and then you can reuse them
anywhere that is MCB compatible. And
finally you get scalable agents. Um if
you run agent workflows on dedicated
infrastructure then you can kind of
separate the where the agent is uh uh
where the agent compute is happening
from uh the client that is being used to
invoke the agent. Uh and that gives
enormous benefits in terms of you know
scalability uh performance and uh
durability as well.
So I've talked about agents as async
workflows. What I mean by that is that
agents can be paused and resumed. uh
they need to await on human feedback in
some cases. Uh they may fail and then
they need to be retrieded. Uh agents
could be triggered or scheduled. It's
not just a chat application that uh is
agentic. You could have a web hook that
triggers an agent or a cron job that you
know triggers an agent every every day
or every week or something. Uh and so
right way to model all of this is as
asynchronous workflows. And so that's
what we do in MCP agent as well. We use
temporal uh as the durable execution
backend to do the compute or the
orchestration of agent execution. So
let's do a quick demo to show what all
of this looks like just to make it more
real. So the first thing you'll see here
is I have uh this task that I want to
build an agent for. Uh in this case it's
a fairly complex task. I'm asking an
agent to load the student's short story
from a markdown file which is this. uh
but we assume this is a student short
story. Uh and then I want to generate a
report uh basically grade this short
story across proofreading uh factual and
logical consistency as well as style
adherence. And by the way for the style
adherence uh I want to use the APA style
guide from this URL. Uh and finally I
want to write that graded report uh to
the markdown file graded report. So the
agent that I've created here is actually
um going to do a couple of things but
first I connect it to a couple of MCP
servers. I have the fetch MCP server
which uh can connect to URLs and get
fetch data from the internet and I have
the file system uh MCP server to
interact with the file system. So right
off the bat because uh of MCP I don't
need to interact with a file system or
uh interact with the internet and and
fetch URLs in a in a unique way. It's
all over the same base protocol and it's
all exposed as tools from these MCP
servers. Uh and then I define a couple
of these agents where I have a finder
agent that can fetch content from the
internet or from disk. I have a writer
agent that can write stuff to disk. Uh I
have a proofreader, a fact checker, a
style enforcer, and then I have an
orchestrator. Recall from you know those
agent patterns I showed you. Uh this one
will basically generate a plan given the
task and it will use uh it will
orchestrate these agents that I've
defined uh in a way that it sees fit. So
this workflow uh is about like a 100
lines of code u and that it's still
doing something fairly sophisticated. So
if we run this,
uh, we're going to use temporal to run
this. And so
I'll kick this off. And you'll see that
the worker job has triggered and it's
going to start executing
u workflow UI. You see that there's a
workflow that's been triggered. And the
first thing you'll see that the agent
does is it actually generates a plan. So
over here you see that it's broken down
the task I gave it the fairly complex
multi-step task uh into a series of
steps that it's going to do. First it's
going to load the student short story uh
and it's going to use the finder agent
for that. In turn the finder agent is
going to use the file system MCP server.
Then it's going to analyze uh the short
story using the proofreader uh the fact
checker the style enforcer and finally
it's gonna uh generate the graded
report.mmarkdown file and write with the
writer agent. And so then you see that
the agent is executing. Uh there's a
whole workflow graph. This can fail at
any step and can be retrieded. It can be
terminated. It can await for human
feedback. And here you see that it
already completed. So we should have a
graded report.mmarkdown file that's
generated for us. Um and if we see
what's in it, you can kind of see that
it did what I asked it to. U factual
consistency APA style guide. Um it was
able to do all this correctly.
Lastly, you can actually do the same
thing now by exposing this agent as an
MCP server. You can connect it to an MCP
client like cloud desktop. Here I have
the agent exposed as an MCP server. And
you see that it exposes itself as
workflows. Uh and so I gave it the same
short story here. Um and I asked it to
grade it use with this basic agent. And
so what it does is it runs the in the
the the workflow. It gives the input of
the story and then it pulls for the
status of that workflow job because note
that the agent is executing in a
different uh execution environment. I
could close my claw desktop and come
back in and it can check the status of
that workflow and get me the results at
a later date. And so the asynchronous
nature of this work of this agent uh
helps me uh kind of you know kick off
agent tasks from anywhere and then it
like once the agent uh completes it
presents me the report over here and so
I can still use this agent in a chatbot
environment. I can run this agent
anywhere that is MCP compatible. Thank
you all for listening to this. There's a
lot more that you can do uh with agents
because of the revolution that MCP is
causing. I'd love to chat more uh in
general about uh the future of agents.
Uh so you can come find me over email,
Twitter or GitHub. Thank you.